so now we've come to a very special part
of our program which is the keynote
address to be given by Laurel Thatcher
aura the 300th anniversary university
professor at Harvard uh she really is
someone who needs no introduction I'm
getting to give a very small one but if
you want to learn more about her you can
find a full biography on the symposium
website along with biographies of the
other speakers professor uhlrich is a
pioneer and anna leader in
conceptualising and animating objects in
teasing out history and producing
knowledge from them and in seeing
objects as cultural actors and agents
one of the first signs of this deep
interest she has is her book the age of
homespun objects and stories in the
creation of an American myth from 2001
but more recently she has launched a
very major initiative called tangible
things making history through objects
which is a gin add course an EDX course
a MOOC if you will open to all and a
book from Oxford University Press that
is just out and this book and the
project and course I'll take a strategy
much like that of our symposium taking
an assemblage of tangible objects and
showing how each can teach us about our
world of course our symposium is also an
assemblage of accomplished specialists
and we're incredibly fortunate to have
our keynote speaker among them please
join me in welcoming Laurel Thatcher
ulrich
this is not a tortilla well I see some
of my TF down there it's not just a
tortilla it is a botanical specimen as
no graphic artifact a historical
document a work of art and a Harvard
curiosity and I want to start with
curiosity one of the things we of course
tell students when we're doing the
history of Harvard museums is about the
cabinet of curiosity which is the
foundation in the Western world of what
we think of today is the modern museum
an assemblage of dairy objects and I'm
interested in that word curiosity
because it turns in a number of
directions it turns toward the object
itself and it turns toward the person
approaching the object a curiosity is an
object it can be an odd thing it can be
a dazzling thing it can be an unexpected
things so there's something about a
curiosity that sets it apart not always
positively you know old curiosity shop
junk assembled can't make your way
through it but also it can be a source
as it was at the time of this museum a
source of wonder but curiosity is also a
desire to know a desire to move beyond
what is right in front of us to learn
more to poke to probe to understand and
the argument that I would like to make
way of keynote today and I think it's
already been made very well is that
engaging readers general public museum
goers and certainly our undergraduate
and graduate students with tangible
things is a way to evoke curiosity that
beginning with almost any object just by
way of look at this thing and what's
there and what engages you and what
provokes you and what do you want to
know so that was the basis of the
project that Julie mentioned the
tangible things project which was not my
invention it's one of those wonderful
opportunities I was in an elevator going
to the top floor of what used to be
called holy out Center and I ran into a
very tall man who was at the time went
through curator at the Harvard Art
Museum my friend Ivan gaskell and he had
just finished a book about one painting
of Vermeer and I had just finished a
book about the age of homespun artifacts
common everyday objects in early America
seems like kind of an odd couple but we
discovered that we had a very common
interest in approach aiding approaching
history through the close encounter with
material things of all sorts and so we
began teaching small seminars together
and eventually we took on something a
bit bold we decided we were going to do
an exhibit in combination with a new
general education course and I think
beginning 2009-2010 we visited at least
17 different Harvard collections and we
went in and talked to curators to
archivists
and we told them our idea for this
exhibit which would be a way to teach
Harvard history through its artifacts
and not the conventional celebratory
Harvard history but the unknown Harvard
history the Harvard history that would
help us situate car Harvard in the world
in relation to issues of race and gender
and environment and imperialism and the
big themes that we deal with in our
historic work and we wanted to invoke
curiosity we wanted the things that
didn't quite fit the things that engaged
these specialists who cared for these
objects the things that challenged the
categories that Harvard like other
universities had inherited from the 19th
century categories the kept art in one
place for mainly Europeans and certain
so-called civilized people as they were
defined in the 19th century and that
assigned anthropology to those who were
considered lower on the scale of
civilization was very frightening
categories that none of us would
consider that we were embracing today
but which still shaped what was in which
museum and how you could have access to
it we also wanted to look at objects
that came into libraries often by
happenstance alongside documenter or
manuscript collections and we wanted to
engage with the science museums and so
we were so fortunate to be able to meet
up with sarah shatner of the wheatland
curator at the collection of historic
scientific instruments who had long
experience of bringing crossing
boundaries and bringing
kind of artifacts together I've done
with Sarah Carter one of our former
students who had completed her PhD and
was teaching in the history and
literature program and then teaming up
with to sarahs we added Sammy Van gerbig
the designer and wonderful photographer
and together with about 50 at least
wonderful supporters in the museums and
libraries we were able to do what we
think may have been the first exhibit
it's a small exhibit incredibly
difficult and time consuming exhibit
that actually brought together artifacts
from at least 17 different Harvard
collections and it was built around the
theme of curiosity and engagement so
this is the Chelsea gallery where the
main part of the exhibit was held we
along the side walls we organized
clusters of objects that defined the
major categories of Harvard's museums
art books and manuscripts anthropology
natural history history and so on and
then in the middle we created what we
called our muddle and these were things
unplaced where did they belong we made
no effort to organize them around
anything we just put them there in clear
view and we said to visitors and our
students where does this belong go ahead
and sort this muddle if you can we've
given them the categories along the wall
and here here's your challenge can you
sort the muddle we also placed guest
objects out of place in seven different
galleries at Harvard so here's a part of
our muddle that brings together a life
mass or a death mask
Abraham Lincoln Samuel Johnson's teapot
some women's suffrage badges and
equipped from the artemus ward museum
one of harvard's little-known
collections and here if you can see it
in the foreground is our tortilla our
tortilla is placed between a cross
section of a transatlantic cable that's
a souvenir from the artemis word house
and a bottle of tapeworms from the
warren anatomical museum these tapers
were collected from Boston Brahmins I'll
have you know so there's no relationship
among these things except i guess the
land of the tapeworms is round the
tortilla is round and the cross-section
of the cable is round but that's an
accidental relationship so what about
our tortilla how have we continued in
our teaching and inner writing to
investigate this truly amazing object
well I start out by saying it is in fact
a botanic specimen we found it because
the librarians and curators in Harvard's
herb area found the most amazing things
and this was one of them it came they're
suggesting they discovered it and showed
it to us you'll notice that the label is
plural but there appears to be only one
object attached to the string in the
hole poked in the round object it's
round if you've ever worked with clay
and made a ball or was dull and then
flattened us you have a rough idea of
how it was made but it's curled as it
gets dried and there's a very sharp
crack extending from the little hole at
the top
which and there are scorch marks and
other kind of marks on the surface now
the label says tortillas name from zea
mays mexico JN rose 1897 and then it
gives a catalog number in the 19th
century botanist at Harvard went out
through the world collecting things
sometimes they found things on the
manure pile outside the Agassiz museum
we have some fungi with that label but
others went to far away places and
Harvard also acquired botanical
collections from other institutions
Joseph Nelson rose worked for the
Smithsonian Institution and his trip to
Mexico in 1896 was primarily focused on
cat toy you can see those in his
photograph he was interested in plants
but this was a period when botanists
were thinking quite a bit about the
human uses of plants and so when he
stopped at the end of the day in little
hat and had tortillas repaired by the
woman of the house he obviously
collected one or more we don't know if
there were others distributed to other
institutions but one of these came to
Harvard this was not the first accession
of tortillas as I began to study this I
was stunned to learn about Edward Palmer
who is considered the father of ethno
botany he was a physician during the
Civil War who stayed in the southwest
and began to collect so this was a real
one of those wonderful finds when I went
to try to
stand one tortilla what did I get a
whole jar of tortillas and these are
even older having been collected by
edward palmer in 1878 and you may not be
able to tell at this distance but the
first tortilla was a little bit squatty
and a little thicker than we might
expect these tortillas look very much
like we would think I was a modern
tortilla that as I began to read the
field reports from Jan rose and Edward
plumber I began to wonder if there was a
nomenclature problem and if one actually
as Rose said was kind of like a hoecake
thrown in the ashes was not actually a
tortilla these looked like those that
were thrown back and forth him the hands
of the Maker having the wet maza ground
on the makati and then slapped onto the
griddle and served hot these looked
somewhat different to me now what's
interesting as we look at this cover on
the bottle is sort of a miracle of
preservation here you know I've seen
collections where anything edible has
long gone to insects or animals they
were very very careful and they were
using some kind of probably white seal
and then the cover over the bottle and
these things and maybe a fair amount of
poison I don't know I did not touch
these objects no one invited me to but
they have survived now what's
interesting to me is the label here from
Edward calmer this is an ethnobotanical
collection so immediately discovering
this object helped me to see an
interrelationship between two worlds in
the late 19th century botany the older
discipline really a foundational
collection at Harvard now coming
together with a developing field of
ethnography and it's not surprising man
that we find some of their word commerce
tortillas not quite so elegantly
displayed in the Peabody Museum and I
can't take time nor am I fully capable
of tracing the complete provenance of
these objects but things move back and
forth any of you have worked in the
natural history and the Peabody Museum
know that the boundaries within those
museums that may seem so firm to us
today as disciplinary boundaries did not
prevail always as objects were coming in
to the museum but ethnobotany at Harvard
quickly was joined by something else and
that something else was called economic
bought me and the most famous example of
that is the commercial museum at
Philadelphia which opened shortly after
the world's columbian exhibition and now
what we're doing is getting into the
really meaty interesting themes for a
historian about our tortilla this is not
simply a collector going out into Mexico
and learning about the culture of
another people this is about a large
process and indeed an international
process of museum collections being tied
into commercial expansion to imperialism
and to the development of world
capitalism ethno botany was part in the
commercial museum of finding useful
products and making them available and
known to entrepreneurs and merchants and
manufacturers in the United States and
assist in its raw economic rise in
the world so this brings us back to the
label on our tortilla catalogue 85 350 a
collection and that is the Oaks Ames
collection of economic botany and oak
seems was not around when this tortilla
came in he eventually his name was
attached to the economic herb area a
barium at Harvard the collection there
is still called The Oaks Ames collection
and he taught a course down at the
Arboretum called economic botany one of
his students later wrote he was far more
interested in poison plants and orchids
than in anything useful which is why the
students called it an economic botany
but in his notes which survived in his
small handwriting he points to some very
interesting developments that would
occur later in the 20th century such as
the discovery that from maize one could
find a substitute for maple syrup no one
from New Hampshire would believe that
but there we are the foundation and our
own University of the gradual move to
what now is forbidden from soft drinks
okay so what do we do with this tortilla
what do we do this is not I don't
specialize in Mexico I don't specialize
in botany I don't even specialize in the
19th or 20th century primarily but I
teach surveys of American history and on
teaching a course on Harvard and one of
my deep specialties of course is the
history of gender and I'm interested in
history of everyday life and I'm
fascinated with his photograph date
unknown obviously much later than our
tortilla
which has been preserved with other
Harvard tortilla collection southwestern
collections and was apparently displayed
either in the peabody museum or the
economic botany exhibit which did exist
and does no more in the Natural History
Museum the this very pretty fide example
of the arduous and complex labor of
producing a fundamental basic food stuff
through grinding and hand hand
production of cake after cake cooking on
the makati now this image which is so
attractive here was used in literature
in the late 19th century to stigmatize
Mexicans as people who rent ground there
women literally into the ground through
the endless work of grinding and to
argue that maze was the corn of passive
people who were incapable of higher
civilization and that what was necessary
is to get machine milling and wheat into
the and this was coming even from the
Mexican government in the late 19th
century to replace the moffat or tea and
a hand ground tortilla with the wet corn
with something milled more efficient
more productive and that began to happen
in many places but something else
interesting began to happen and that is
as migration continued the corn masa
came into Hispanic culture somebody in a
service station in Texas in the 1950s
invented with an extruder into hot oil
something that became the frito so now
the food of the overburdened
Mexican woman has become the convenience
food of the blue-eyed american woman who
can make a quick salad out of get this
mayonnaise Fritos and canned corn maybe
with the out of little bit of green
pepper so in our class we do a lot with
the evolution of the tortilla over time
one of the reasons the object is so
interesting to people and such an object
of curiosity it's because nobody can
figure out why it's in a museum well
it's there because at once wasn't well
known it was considered exotic it's so
common today and to end the way you know
if you've got a good historical topic is
if something doesn't make sense and then
you think something's changed and we
need to understand how that has changed
so this has become a classic in our
course tangible things where we put
students to work with baggies of freedom
doing clothes looking an examination of
the object and we think about the
evolution from freedom kids in the 1950s
to the G anybody remember the frito
Bandito of the night late 60s and early
70s the pushback of course and that
brings me to my third point this
tortilla is a botanic specimen and
ethnographic artifact Canady a work of
art man a los angeles artist named joe
Bravo accidentally one day started
painting on tortillas he now has an
international reputation for tortilla
art what's strange to me anyway is that
he does this art on wheat flour
tortillas which doesn't seem to me
nearly subversive
so that brings me back to this picture
close-up picture of our tortilla which I
have looked at many times as I've looked
at the tortilla clearly the scorch marks
are important and suggest a way in which
this object was cooked but if you look
very closely what you see in this
amazing material that has been
transformed into a edible once edible
product our little tiny black flecks now
yesterday I looked on the internet and
put black flecks on corn chips and black
flecks on cornmeal and I discovered
there's quite a debate going on in on
the internet on you know those ask a
question sources about whether these
black flecks or bugs or black ground
black pepper which tells us our lack of
botanical knowledge of knowledge of
Whole Foods I suppose starting from
scratch in making things the black
flecks are of course the result of the
ripening of the hilum that what is
sometimes called the navel of a seed
when it's fully ripe and you're using we
don't get it that it's not black when we
eat sweet corn but when you eat when you
have filled corn that's fully right
there's this little black speck and the
black Fleck in the tortilla is an
implement this is a whole grain that has
entirely used and when you get a
perfectly yellow tortilla with lots of
interesting additives it will never have
a black speck because they are afraid
the consumers will think it's bugs or
black pepper or not although some
Millers have managed to figure out how
to add
black specs for those who expect a whole
grain product so it becomes a very very
interesting problem in marketing that
has produced some scholarly literature
actually so who was i I knew nothing
about tortillas I went into a collection
at Harvard and saw something really
weird and because I wanted to help my
students understand it I began to do
research and they began to do research
as well research in the collections
research into the larger culture and it
was a transformative experience for me
and believe me none of our students
wanted to eat the Fritos after they had
examined them so here is the corn in the
cmas from a beautiful photograph from
Sammy younger eek I know want to know
more about botany never thought that
would ever happen to me so i'ma show up
in one of your classes one of these days
I think that Sammy Denver big picture of
the tortilla may be an even more
interesting work of art than Joe Bravo's
tortilla although I find his tortilla
paintings interesting and so I just want
to close with a few more of Sammys
pictures to tell you what can happen
when we take our own curiosity to
curious things that are all around us
the fairy armadillo collected by the
agassi's on the Thayer expedition to
Brazil a pot from the Semitic Museum
excavated it may be in a medicine pot
that has created this fabulous
iridescent that Tiffany and others in
the late
19th century tried to imitate a turtle
that apparently henry david thoreau
collected at walden pond and through
samy's camera I a very sense of the
living specimen that is encased in that
bottle an epaulette from the artemus
ward museum that came as a fantastic and
probably an accurate story but the
spangles amet epaulet when we look at it
closely all these museums contributed to
tangible things I am deeply grateful for
my colleagues we work together and had
so much fun we didn't want to quit so we
wrote a book but we could not have done
any of this without the registrar's the
curators the Conservatives the
librarians the archivist that made it
possible and I think we'll all agree
with Sarah Putnam hoop and on her quilt
great objects make great minds thank you
does the board objects they are really
mean physical optics or aims who knows I
think you know how they more than that's
what's fun um it comes from I think it's
an objective or Ames probably but we
borrowed that I think it comes from
Edward Young's night thoughts she and
she took some of her she has
inscriptions on all over the quilt which
is disintegrating you can hardly you
know it's a marvelously ragged artifact
but the inscriptions were fascinating
it's not a question its but either a
comment my name is khan chaganti I'm
from the herbarium I'm a botanist I just
wanted to mention that zea mays whenever
someone is eating a popcorn they are
eating really a fruit it's a grass fruit
when you are eating an apple you are not
technically eating a fruit but when you
are eating your popcorn you are really
eating your fruit this is the technical
aspect and i also want to mention that
there has been some controversy whether
zea mays is really native to this place
or it has it was native to the world
world whether there was any kind of
exchange this kind of yes discussion has
been going on very much an important
part of the Atlantic's exchange and you
know rich and deep literature I mean you
know we could do a whole semester on on
maize and its various thank you very
much my name is Rebecca Kaufman and I'm
from the Cambridge community and an
archivist for the Steiff company I'm
curious about the people that you've
worked with in putting together this
collection of collections were those
people collectors themselves beyond
their their professional interest in
these things did they have collections
of their own oh that's a great question
that you're asking I can't say for all
of them there Harvard employees all of
them that we worked with and working in
museums I will say for myself I have
a a collection of ordinary objects that
i use in teaching because they can be
manipulated but i don't want to take
care of anything 118 years old or
anything valuable and i think some of my
other colleagues feel that way some like
to collect and some say no that's not
what I do it's a interesting question
I'd like us to thank very much our
keynote speaker
you